Chad hold for you when you knew you
wanted to be an actor I knew I wanted to
be an actor at a very young age I was
always making movies with the video
camera that was like this big back in
the day and always you know putting on
skits for my parents and whoever would
watch and and then as I got into like
high school and stuff I wanted to be a
cop like my dad I wanted to be a police
officer so I went to the college and got
a you know signed up to be a police
officer the whole nine yards and then
they were auditioning for a play in high
school
and a buddy to me goes hey you should
audition I'm like I don't want to
audition no way no way go he's like come
on auditions for Guys and Dolls
so I auditioned and I'm not a very good
singer I'm a terrible singer in fact but
I got a small part and then I got
onstage and then I realized then that
was what I was good at I'm not a sports
guy I was not a football player in high
school you know acting was my thing and
once I locked onto that that I knew I
had a very young age that that's what I
was going to do nobody was gonna tell me
different and you know looking back 22
years you know later I'm really thankful
that it happened because it doesn't
happen for a lot of people here that are
trying to break into this crazy industry
so that's interesting so cuz I know a
lot of people that come from like
families with law enforcement and
usually there's a long line of them and
a lot of people are are there when you
drive by let's say a police officer does
it ever register in your mind like hmm
you know that could be me right there
had it been a couple change of events no
because I don't have that inside of me
you know I'm not I'm not a guy he's
gonna take down another guy you know huh
I'm not a guy that can pull a gun and
make a life-and-death decision you know
with the exception of a few bad apples I
have nothing but respect for the law
enforcement and what they do I think
they're true heroes
whenever I see a cop I think of my dad
and I think of him putting himself out
there in harm's way and helping people
and being respectful to people
and treating everybody with respect so
that's what I think about when I see
please officer is and I'm grateful that
we have them did you feel any pressure
though to take another course or they
were supportive
my parents were 100% supportive of me
from the very beginning because they saw
they saw that just this was what I
wanted to do this is what I was good at
and a lot of actors that I've talked to
you didn't have parental support you
know which which makes me sad because
that's all I have is the support even to
this day I mean there are a hundred
percent behind me you know if I book
something that they're a fan of it's
always really exciting I remember when I
got ER and my mom flipped out because it
was really big back in the time and and
George Clooney and all of this cool
stuff and and or if there's a fun action
movie my dad will come and visit me on
set so it's they're amazing parents and
I've been so lucky to have their support
and it helps I mean you know this
business is very unforgiving in a lot of
ways in terms of the rejection and the
honesty that you get as an actor so
having that support when you fall down
makes a difference well I have a quote
from another actor this time and it is
the further you get away from yourself
the more challenging it is not to be in
your comfort zone is great fun and this
is from none other than Benedict
Cumberbatch so do you like play roles
that are sort of your polar opposite or
maybe you're more of a chameleon you can
be many things many days and that's okay
because that's all part of it yeah
yeah I I have been lucky that I can be a
chameleon I think I'm more of a
character actor so I don't really fit I
don't think into any category and it is
a challenge to to play somebody that's
farthest away from you and sometimes
most of the time when you get those
sides or you get that audition you're
running from it feel like I'm that's not
I can't do that that's not that's not
for me and they're never gonna pick me
they're never gonna choose me
and then you find a way to do it you go
in and you show them something that they
didn't think about and then you end up
getting it that's happened a lot of the
times and then it it does challenge you
to go deeper and to get in the mind of
somebody else and I love playing
somebody that's so completely opposite
of me but there's always a little part
of you I think in every character that
you portray because you have to start
from somewhere you have to start from
you you have to start from your own
experiences and then kind of go from
there so let's take that if you let's
suppose you get a callback for something
that you're already maybe nervous about
but of course they love you would you
then go and maybe start researching
people of that type or it would it keep
in your mind when you see someone let's
say the grocery store similar to that
what's your process um my process
usually is honestly I just once you read
an audition you just kind of get this
sort of energy that comes from reading
the lines and and and then I kind of I
don't even know what happens I don't
even think you can sort of put a a word
on it just you get this sort of like
okay that's how I'm gonna do it and it
might be wrong but you make a choice and
then you go in there and hopefully they
like your choice and then sometimes you
go in there and they're like no we want
to see it a completely different way and
then you have to sort of take direction
on a dime because that's also part of
the process I think they want to see you
the character as the character but they
also want to see how well you can take
direction in an instant because that's
what it's like an onset you have to be
able to meld yourself you know and take
direction and go a different way if it's
not working I know this is like a weird
like creepy question but are you a
people watcher and I don't mean it in
like like no it could be so many people
but in terms of studying human nature
and observing people is what I meant
yeah yeah I am an observer I'm the guy
who will be on the wall at a party just
kind of watching I'm
not the guy who's like you know I'm I
watch people and now you know it's
tricky when they watch you so it's kind
of an interesting dichotomy is that
right that's right weird dichotomy use
it go for it really yes
put it so it's interesting when you you
you know when once fame sort of enters
the food that the picture you know and
then you have people staring at you and
so it makes it interesting right for the
times that maybe you feel you can blend
in more which probably's is not often
but like let's suppose you have a hat on
or you just feel like maybe you're in a
space where no one's really - celebrity
focused it's maybe another town or
something what what catches your eye
about people in terms of character study
like is there you know because for me
I'll see people at the grocery store and
it'll be the person that's not really
that glamorous but they're just doing
their own thing and I'm like zeroed in
on that totally it's the people that
have like interesting tics or walks or
that have a disability you know I'm
fascinated by how they operate with life
in how they're interacting with people
so I'll really zero in on on that
because it's something I don't know but
yeah you know people do catch my eye and
and I'll try not to stare because his
room is there sure but I want to know
you know and a lot of those things I
have brought in in different characters
you know I'll see somebody doing it not
remember it from years ago like okay
that might work for this so observing is
is key I think to acting you know yeah
and on the flip side when the eyes are
on you and maybe you're in more of a
public setting how's that feel do you
ever feel pressure to be superhuman in
some ways yeah I mean you have to be
well it depends on where it's at if
you're at an event you know where people
are there to see you yes you know you're
on and it's a your present and
and it's a beautiful thing and then
sometimes you know I will have my hat on
somewhere and I'm completely not even
thinking about it and then somebody will
recognize you or and it just catches you
off-guard you know and then you're like
okay wait yeah I am in the public eye I
have to remind myself you know cuz I'll
forget especially like it here in LA
where was this kind of our safe zone as
actors in a way but still be at the
Ralph's you know we're hoping that and
raus is a local grocery Mart in LA is we
love it but I'll be there now thinking
of it and then somebody will say hey or
you know I'm like oh wait you're right
because when you go out of La that's
when people get really really excited
you know because they don't see
celebrities all the time you know it's
not in LA we see everybody you know and
we sort of like okay and this is where
they live and we respect that but when
you go outside of LA that's when that's
when people get really pumped not to say
that they don't hear but it's just a
different thing right
just because today we're in this new age
of phones and you know people get in
fights on subways instead of calling 911
one they just take their phone out do
you feel any pressure that even if
you're just you know at Ralph's and
you're you know looking at the rock
stars or that you know whatever energy
drinks or something and then you feel
someone's presence do you feel a little
more self-conscious
absolutely absolutely does make you feel
self-conscious when someone's sitting
there kinda see and I always feel it I
can whenever I go into someplace now
because of being recognizable I will
sort of case the place before now I'll
go in somewhere you know kind of be like
okay this person will probably recognize
me and then you feel it I can always
feel there'll be like a hush behind me
you know what I mean people will be
talking and you feel this hush and you
know that they're saying something about
you and especially now you know people
can get on their phones and they'll be
like hey Chad your name's Chad right and
I'll be like yeah you got your phone
right back in a day you know it was like
hey Jesse hey ash and I still get that a
lot but now the phones people can just
go and type your name right away and
figure out who you are on the flip side
I think these are weapons too I think we
do have to be careful in these times
because I've had plenty of people just
all of a sudden just do just do this to
me and I'm like do you want a photo yeah
yeah yeah well how about you get in it
and how about I take the photo and we
can both be in it
Fame is an interesting thing to watch
people's how they react to it it's
almost like some people can show and be
cool some people lose their bodily
functions it's it's fascinating to watch
yeah and then some people will have a
conversation about you and we'll be just
as close as we are and they'll be
talking as if you don't exist like
you're an object it's fascinating it's
fascinating and I'd really try I don't
take it personally you know in a minute
I understand that's the inner workings
of Fame and how it works and celebrity
but a lot of times it can be invasive
sometimes you know when people you know
follow you into a restroom or you know
these things happen yeah but
ninety-eight percent of time it's love
and it's I feel really really fortunate
to have been in in projects that people
know and they recognize me and that's
you know people are recognizing your
work and that's that's a great thing I
know I've heard Marc Maron talk about he
could feel the room when he would go up
on stage and tell what was going to be
sort of a crowd that he would play to
and they would love and then vice versa
and I think I heard nikki sixx say the
same thing he was very sensitive to the
energy around him so when you feel that
maybe the energy isn't totally friendly
what do you do do you leave I leave okay
I leave I've been in plenty of
situations where people have wanted to
fight me because I'm famous because
maybe there
were people in the room or a female hope
that got excited and wanted a photo and
I've had several people over the years
want to come out and hurt me and I just
very cool they'd be like it's not it's
not me that you're upset with here -
whatever you got going on in it and it's
cool and then I'll leave
I'll never stick around if somebody
wants to challenge me because you know
hey Hollywood you know I don't I don't
put up with it so but you know it
happens it's yeah I always say if Fame
is a double-edged sword right and I just
have one last question then we'll move
on sure I feel like I'm grilling you
guys all right when when you felt that
that changed in your life because I'm
sure there were times when in the
beginning you could go places and then
maybe people didn't have their agendas
whether it was they were in love with
you or they were jealous of you whatever
it was but when you felt it shift how
was that for you I remember the moment
that shifted and that was the day after
fast nefarious came out we my family and
I had gone to see it like in a town near
Seattle and we win it in fear we watched
it and then we came out and I got mauled
by people it was insane and I was like
whoa you know because I didn't expect
that movie you know my mom asked me to
we wanted to have a film premiere
of The Fast and the Furious back home
and I said I go mom no one's ever gonna
see this film because I was ignorant I
was very young and I didn't understand
again you know we go back to being young
and sort of having those big hits you
know you don't realize what you have and
that movie taught me that you never
never know and I was so lucky to be a
part of this huge phenomenon and to this
day people recognize Jesse left and
right so I'm really fortunate and I and
then after I got mold I went to another
place and got mold again and then it
just kept happening and I remember that
night just like it freaked me out so
much and I was
like I you know was crying I was like I
was really upset and my mom was there
and I'm like this things have changed
things have definitely changed and it
was a tearful joy but also scary because
it's like whoa you feel the shift and
then it hasn't been the same sense and
so you kind of learn to adjust and you
know and again I'm very thankful for it
is a it's an interesting position to be
in
yeah I think a lot of people don't think
about that because we're in such an era
of people wanting to be famous whether
it's on tumblr Instagram Twitter
whatever but then there is a
double-edged sword but then you know the
Chad that was the little boy in the
second grade and you know a different
Chad then the way maybe the world
projects so it's got to be an
interesting thing because you know
yourself as Chad the human and other
people see as an actor superhuman you
know right they do a lot of people see
their perception mmm what they want to
think of you it doesn't it's not who I
am it's just what they see and what they
want to sort of put into into their
little box about who you are and we do
that with you think a lot of celebrities
we just truly don't know you know my
favorite is when somebody says Oh
so-and-so's an a-hole I go really
have you ever met this person and we're
talking about a celebrity oh this
celebrity is in an a-hole really have
you ever met them no and I'm like even
you can never say that about this person
you can't because somebody outside out
there saying that Chad Lindberg is an
a-hole because I looked in a certain way
or I didn't hear them and my Anejo know
so it's interesting when people say that
I just I just think you know unless you
know somebody in this business you don't
know them so sure well I know Mickey
Rourke was interviewed and he said that
LA was a town built on envy and I think
that is true
in many ways and and so I think
sometimes a lot of it comes from that
sure anyway thank you yeah thank you
and I love hearing those story I mean
from guys that have been around doing
this for years you know I've been doing
this a long time but he's been doing a
long time and it's interesting to hear
similar stories I yeah it was a Piers
Morgan interview those the Mickey Rourke
excellent Wow okay cool so we'll move on
from awesome have you always been
obsessive about your career right um yes
I think you need to be somewhat
obsessive in a healthy way you have to
have a healthy ego to be in this
business you have to know you're good in
order to succeed in this business if you
don't believe that you're good you know
then then you got to go do something
else because you're gonna get hit time
and time again about how you look you
know you're this you're that you're too
old you're too so you have to have a
thick skin and yeah I you know just
actually I was periscoping with somebody
in the car before this and I said I was
doing this interview and this guy goes
hey get me into the business and I said
get yourself into the business like cuz
it's hard work you know um and he's like
I want to be an actor and I said well
unless you are an actor and you are a
hundred and ten percent don't do it
because it's tough again I've had a long
beautiful resume but it's still hard
even to this day I have a movie coming
out next year but also I haven't worked
in almost eight years so it's like you
have to be able to sustain yourself
somehow through this business and you
know it's tough so yeah you have to you
have to be obsessive to a healthy degree
you know you don't want to be unhealthy
which is the other way around and
tearing yourself down because as actors
I think we are our own worst enemy you
know it's much easier to be loving and
and inviting to somebody else but how
are you to you towards yourself and has
actors man all of our our emotions are
on on the level on the skin level right
here they're always accessible so you
know it's a daily I think thing to
remind yourself that you got to love
yourself and you got to push yourself in
this business and don't become
complacent that's interesting so with
with loving yourself do you find that
there are things outside of the business
that you can focus on when maybe stuff
drives up for a little bit which I know
it happens for every actor and then all
of a sudden all these projects come at
the same time so are there other things
outside of the business that maybe you
can focus on and then yeah I I say
follow your passions no matter where
they lead no matter what they are I you
know I've been acting for a long time
who I am but I also started paranoia
investigating which I do relentlessly
it's also become a religion for me in a
way it's kind of how I a spirituality I
should say not religion this is
something I've been doing for God seven
years now and I go out and and Perrineau
investigate now I lead tours myself and
sort of help facilitate conversations
between the living and the dead I did a
show called go stalkers where they they
put me in another guy named John Tenney
I don't do these really haunted places
and left us alone overnight by myself
home so yeah and now that's you know
another passion of mine that has helped
sort of fill up the the times when I'm
not working as an actor I do tons of
investigations I lead people now and
take them out to really haunted places
and so it's good fun it's interesting I
know with intuition we all have it but
some people have it more two different
degrees or they can develop it more was
that something that you always had from
the time you were little I think so I
think so I've always been a very open
person I had a
Dizzy's and I was younger called Reye's
syndrome and it's a taxi immune system
and I remember the doctors basically
told my parents he's going to die within
a few hours go say goodbye and I was
maybe maybe at the time and I was
expected to die and I think in that
period of time because I was bedridden
for about two months I'm not two months
excuse me two weeks in the hospital I
kind of floated in and out of death sort
of kind of went back and forth what did
that had something to do with me being
open and being able to see ghosts and
hear them I don't know I don't know and
then there were other kids in that
hospital that died and I lived so I
don't know if that had anything to do
with me being open near-death
experiences I do believe open people up
in a way that probably they needed
something happens like this is going way
off of active yeah but you know it all
plays into each other I think when you
have a near-death experience we need to
look at that as an awakening experience
and use that to awaken being intuitive I
know probably pick up hits about whether
it's a place whether it's a person how
much do you say because sometimes as
intuitive people we have to learn to
keep our mouths shut because we're we
know things or we at least we feel we do
but maybe it's not our place to say them
in the course of your day-to-day life
because you have this ability it's one
thing if you go into an area but let's
suppose you're in LA and LA is is
sometimes not the place to be the most
brutally honest but but I think as being
a person that has sort of somebody that
they're answering to that's maybe your
consciousness about you maybe I'm not
describing it right when do you fill it
to yourself because I know that's a
problem with a lot of intuitive people I
try to feel I mean usually something
will happen
I'll be like I dreamt that or I was
thinking about this person you know and
then you'll get a phone call or
something like that so I think we're all
tied in in some weird way we have to I
mean in getting it ties into acting we
need to pay attention to our intuition
you know I think a lot of time
well that nagging feeling will come up
about something and we don't listen to
it you know then something happens like
we should listen to that you know so
yeah you know if there's something that
I feel like needs to be said I'll say
but I think a lot of I think there's a
lot of psychics or mediums or however
you want to say it that put forth that
information without being asked and I
don't think that's the right thing you
know usually if somebody says I'm like
this I'm like that I don't think you are
you know what I mean if you have to tell
somebody that you're at this you know oh
I'm an actor I don't know that you are
because if you really are do you have to
say you know what I mean you have to
validate yourself I know I feel I could
hear that a lot in this town especially
tour I bet that's really interesting
then when you're in a scene with some
because if you let's just remember
saying without putting a label on it
just being extra sensitive to energy
right how is that that must be amazing
or but it could also be interesting if
maybe there's friction how do you how do
you deal with that emotions because I
know a lot of people that are very
sensitive it's a lot of stimuli that
comes out though well when you're acting
I feel like you got to use whatever
stimuli whatever stimuli you can grab
onto to sort of like get you into a
scene i working on sons of anarchy and i
had known a couple of the guys on this
set and i did a guest start and then
halfway through the day i walked over to
where they were all kind of hanging out
and i won't mention which one of the
guys but he goes get out of here this
isn't your scene
get out of here this isn't your scene
and we were I about to do a scene
together and I was like hurt you know
and like a couple of actors they were
like oh don't worry about it it's okay
you know it's don't don't don't take it
personally so I walked away and I was
like you know and then it got me going
you know and then I used it in the scene
and then but and you get there so it
worked not something I would do
to another actor however you know
however it comes out and sometimes you
got to take it there in order to go
somewhere else so yeah you have to be
sensitive to somebody else in the scene
that you're acting with and if it's not
going that placed and you need to do
something to switch it up so I was doing
a movie called push years ago and chasse
Palma Terry was in the movie and in the
movie he kind of plays like my father
figure and we all know Chazz Palma Terry
is a great actor tall intimidating man
very very generous very nice so in this
scene I am supposed to come in and tell
him that I lost all this money and I
need help and I need I need it I needed
him to bail me out of this life-or-death
situation so I kept coming into the
scene I'm supposed to be crying and this
and I wasn't bringing in Pierhead
I was stinking up the room and I
couldn't get there and so all right
maybe you know take five or whatever I
come in goes what did you say he grabs
me pulls me to him and goes slaps me
across the face wham like this the whole
set you can hear a pin drop and I was
like that started crying he goes what'd
you say he goes come here and he grabs
me again slaps me again and man's got
hands you know wham I'm like oh my god
and then I started to cry and started to
get into it and before you know it I'm
buddy
and cut director yells cut he's like
that's amazing thank you so much and I
go outside and I ball cried and I cried
and I cried because I just got my ass
handed to me by a football player in
this business right and I went inside
and Chazz he grabbed me and he pulled me
in and gave me a big huge hug and goes
don't take it personally kid he goes to
NATO slap me and if you go back and you
watch I think it was a Bronx Tale and in
a scene they're slapping each other or
DeNiro slaps him or something like that
and they would keep doing that back and
forth until they actually gotten to the
scene so I felt it was a huge honor that
he trusted me enough to slap me and then
he told that Sid the story on Conan
because Conan was like do actors get
intimidated of you
he was like yeah and he started to tell
the story about how he slapped me and
but we got there so he was sensitive to
me and and and he was also being very
generous and helping me it wasn't about
him and I think that's something that we
need to do as actors is is is be
generous to the other actor because if
you we both need to look good you know
it's not all about me and my coverage no
like we need to be generous to the other
actor we need to stand there and while
they're doing their coverage and give
them their lines because it's it's the
right thing to do it was almost like a
rite of passage and somewhat like he was
like a hazing exactly what I felt it was
it was a graduation almost when I got
slapped by Chas momentary and taught me
a lot they taught me you know if it's
not going somewhere switch it up do
something different I don't think I've
slapped anybody maybe when I'm like 50
you know Tamim and the new young guys
coming on don't take it personally kid
Palma Terry slab moved here to Los
Angeles in 95 1996 96
yeah do you think you work harder now
than you did in 96 or is it a different
type of working at it it's a different
type of working at it like I said you
know when I first moved here you know I
had blinders on and you don't really
realize what you're getting into you
know what this means and so I you know I
worked very hard to break into the
business and I got very lucky that
happened performing at a very early age
you have to work just as hard you know
if not harder once you do get some
success I think you have to keep working
to hopefully keep that success although
this business is up and down up and down
it doesn't really seem to be anywhere in
between at least for me it kind of seems
like you have those good years and then
you have years where you don't work I
met Connor and you have to write it out
and a lot of actors will ask what's what
what do you suggest what what's your
advice and I said the persistence is key
don't leave you can be the last one
standing I think is what I my acting
coach said to me be the last one
standing so you have to don't give up
because if you give up that might have
been the next day where you got that
audition that's gonna change your life
so if it's who you are don't give up you
can't as much as you want to as much as
I've have many a days where I'm like I
just want to say peace out and run and
go the other way but then I would be
miserable you know because it's Who I am
so I know we talked about this a long
time ago in 2012 I think that you'd said
that you you knew that this was a choice
you were gonna make but maybe you could
revisit it for us where do you remember
the exact moment where you said this is
what I want like it's not gonna be okay
if if I you know this isn't gonna work
when I get a job you know go back to
like a vocational school and try to like
get a desk job or so I mean when did you
know that this was for you I knew I knew
I knew in in high school that's what
wanted to do at a very early age nobody
was going to tell me differently and you
know looking back I don't think I'm not
the guy to sit behind a desk at an
office not that there's anything wrong
with that it's just not who I am I'm
kind of used to the uncertainty now in
sort of the crazy off life it is to be
an actor um it's not a regular thing
there's no certainty in this business
there's a mostly uncertainty so you kind
of have to roll with that that's
interesting so being comfortable with
being uncomfortable exactly exactly yeah
it's being comfortable with being
uncomfortable which is pretty much all
the time and then you'll have a couple
great months where you work and you go
on location last movie I did with the
Bulgaria for a month and a half and got
to work with Antonio Banderas and Sir
Ben Kingsley and I was amazing you know
and then you come back and it's back to
reality so it's like you know it's a
very weird weird business it changes on
a dime and that's what I love about it
you know you just never know again so
when those days come when stuff isn't
happening and believe me for us we have
them too even just with our little
outlet we're like stuff's just not
there's the needle isn't moving at all
so what do you do because I it's easy to
get frustrated I mean I get frustrated
with um again you know I I focus a lot
of my attention you know especially
those days where it's not working out or
it's really slow I will again do the
paranormal investigating I take people
out and show them I do a lot of
investigations I've got a couple coming
up here in the next couple weeks and so
I really keep keep busy doing that
because it's you know the uncertainty of
acting is it's quite frequent are them
just curious are these crime scenes
where this is like maybe for someone
who's about to buy a new house and
there's been reported there there's a
death or how does this work
oh no I mean
like I'll take people out to like really
haunted haunted locations it could be an
insane asylum it could be I'm going to
Gettysburg here and about a week when I
film go stalkers they put us in the
craziest locations prisons you know and
I would go in by myself with a camera
much like this and my sticks and a
handheld camera and a flashlight and
that's all that I would have as my
safety so I really learned a lot about
fear a whole different kind of fear but
yeah it could be a number of different
kinds of places that are really haunted
I think the ghosts are all around us
spirits are all around us but we really
don't think about it because we think we
have to be in a haunted house for this
to happen well I think they're
everywhere just like people do you ever
I miss you most of time what I've heard
is a lot of the spirits aren't
unfriendly but when you've maybe
encountered someone that's been in a bad
place before they've passed on do you
does it affect you oh yeah definitely
definitely you can walk into one of
these places and feel what happened
there some places make you sick make you
throw up make your heart race
yeah it's you're dealing with things
that we cannot put an answer on we can't
put a label you know it's the
supernatural so so what was the
beginning of the question
I'm just wondering if sometimes if the
energy from someone that's in a lot of
pain that hasn't crossed over maybe they
don't fully know that they're dead you
know oh right right right they don't
does it ever affect you does it ever
because you're absorbing absolutely yeah
it affects me almost every time and each
place can be different in their energy
sometimes it's a very tame environment
and
and then you'll go into like an insane
asylum and I'll have a woman laugh in my
face that I can't see and then I jumped
like 10 feet back because it knocked the
wind out of me and then I went upstairs
so this is sane asylum and I hear this
ooh this man moaning and you see me go
lock jaw because I just was frozen with
fear and a misconception about ghosts is
that if something happens well then it's
evil you know and it's it's a bad it's
bad they want something from me I felt
it touched me it must be evil and it's a
miscount it's it's a it's a it's usually
misconstrued because what happens when a
child wants her attention they pull
scratch I mean so when people get pushed
or scratched or pulled it's just them
saying hey I'm here and this is how
you're gonna know that I'm here it's by
doing something that you're gonna
undeniably feel or see so and yes there
are evil spirits there's bad and good
and everything but you know just because
something happens to us doesn't mean
that it's bad necessarily how did you
know that you I mean because mediumship
is that is that what we're talking about
here sort of here people have passed on
yeah I guess mediumship um I don't know
I don't know what you would call it I I
guess I'm an investigator investigator
of truth you know I want to know what's
going on because there are so many weird
things in this world that we don't give
credit to you know we walk around like
this is normal I don't think this is
normal
I don't think humans are normal this has
been happening for hundreds and hundreds
of years so it must be okay but I think
that where the aliens walking around
with these goofy limbs and like oh how
are you how are you you know what I mean
I think that's crazy I do I do I think
that is bizarre in itself and a lot of
people just write it off daily as being
normal when I think
I don't think it is normal it's it's a
beautiful thing and I think past that
you know there are ghosts there are
spirits there are otherworldly creatures
that we just don't give credit to I
think they exist I've seen a lot of
weird things experience a lot of weird
things that provoke questions and that's
why I do it because it makes you ask
something deeper you know when you have
an experience nothing makes you feel
more alive when you're doing with the
dead you know when you have an
experience from a ghost or a spirit or
something has a very serious energy to
it and you feel that it you'll never
forget it
have you had dreams about booking
certain rules or that you weren't going
to get them and then it happened
occasionally yeah I have a dream that
like I get a call from my manager and
it's like oh you got the part you know
and sometimes it doesn't happen and then
sometimes it does you know because
usually I will no not always but when I
get sides from an audition I will know
okay that's that's something I'm gonna
get or I'm close to getting or that's in
my wheelhouse
so you know again you got to pay
attention to your intuition
Chad was there ever a time when you said
no to television work yes there there
there was a time you know when I first
got here that we had a pager and I had
to pull over to my you know call my
agent on the phone and find a pay phone
and it's just back in those days usually
it was like if you were a movie actor
you were a movie actor and if you were a
TV actor you were a TV actor and there
really wasn't any in-between and there
was a time when again I was very very
young and I thought well no I don't I
don't want to do television I don't I
don't want to do television that was
getting handed a a series you know I now
I'm like of course I want to do
television you know some of the greatest
stuff you can see right now is on TV but
now with actors you can do there are so
many mediums with social media you know
you got YouTube stars you got vine stars
you got all these different people now
but back when I started it was there was
no internet
you know it was movies and TV and I've
been really grateful to to be able to
flow back and forth and do film and do
television I think I've been on just
about every show that's ever come out
which is cool and I you know I feel
blessed to have be able to do both but
there was a time when I was young when I
thought maybe I didn't want to do a TV
and I just want to do a movies and
that's that's ignorant thinking young
thinking okay and so if you were to hear
suppose you were with a group of actors
who were maybe early 20s and and you
heard them say that I'm not I just only
want to do this medium not that would
you say anything or would you just kind
of let them develop their own process no
I'd say something we'll say say you're
an idiot just be honest and say don't be
an idiot you know you know and I have
come across actors that say oh I don't
want to do this right guy you know I got
a don't let me here don't let me hear
you complain about working or about
being in this business we are lucky to
be in this business and to be working
and nothing irritates me more than when
I hear other actors bitching about their
work and being on set and bitching about
this and bitching about that shut your
mouth and work you know um you know if
you want a take it I'll swear and
do that but don't bring it to set
because we are very lucky to do what we
do and granted there have been times
when I was much younger that I I didn't
realize what I had you know and I didn't
have many older actors saying to me and
hey you know shape up it's not going to
be like this you know what I mean and
you know it changed it changed now I'm
I'm so grateful to to work no matter
what it is TV film I mean you know
something off the internet
so I would say hey why is it up
wise up and and be appreciative of the
work because most likely your
opportunity is not going to be here
tomorrow
I think for so many people that are
young they don't realize there's so many
vanilla there's so much opportunity
because the world treats you differently
when you're 19 and I've come from
somewhere else right but then after
maybe even mid-20s it just changes
because it's not seen as like the young
ingénue right so is it a process you
think a lot of people once they stay in
this town they began to realize and
change themselves absolutely i I think I
call it the LA machine you cannot or the
Hollywood machine no one escapes it you
know no one escapes it everybody goes
through the same exact thing it's the
same exact story it's like when we spoke
about my big breaking about you know all
those actors living in that one house
together now it's some other young
actors and and and that are coming to
town and so it's like everybody has the
same story just tells it differently
everybody has the same obstacles in this
town I mean just a little bit different
you know is where you know my story was
about my looks and you know I wasn't
good-looking enough or or you know he's
not a leading man you know and then I
had my buddy
it was very very good-looking and
getting the complete opposite well
you're too good-looking
you know like what do you guys want you
know so you put up with a lot of that in
this industry and it's tough it's tough
you know no one wants to hear exactly
how you look you know at the saw this
this industry is very honest and and now
at 40 years old I Know Who I am I know
where I fit and I'm okay with playing a
computer geek whereas before you know
when I was young I took it personally I
took it very personally because in my
mind I thought I was Leonardo DiCaprio
maybe that was a little bit of a
delusion and myself but that's how I had
to see myself in order just to like do
it and then I started getting all this
computer geek roles and I'm like but I'm
not I'm not a I'm not that guy and then
time I'd realized well that's my
wheelhouse and that's those are the
roles that are coming towards my way and
now I embrace everything you know it's
not about being a leading man and about
being this particular actor it's about
being you and a being and knowing what
you bring to the table what you're good
at and I feel like I've after all this
time realized you know what I am good at
and and looking forward to being
challenged now that I'm 40 and grown
into myself I I'm looking for that next
next challenge are you okay with being a
sexy paranormal and again you know no
you know when people ask me what I do I
am an actor and I'm a paranormal
investigator it is
to two things that I take very seriously
and and it's worked out it's worked out
in both realms so realms so I feel very
fortunate to be where I'm at and to have
works like I have and like we talked
about it doesn't happen for everybody
and it's scary well I mean not everybody
has the ability to light themselves or
love themselves because of some label
whether it's even true or not that
someone else in power has put on them
right have you been able to come to that
place and what advice do you have for
other people I mean just as a woman I
know there's so much pressure whether
it's looks--wait
whether you're married or not yeah and
and I think a lot of women don't love
themselves I'm sure it's interesting to
hear that men go through it - yeah
that's it's kind of a shocker for me I
didn't realize it but how do you come to
terms with loving yourself no matter
what the label is someone puts on you
what even if it's not true the label
they're putting on I think it's tough I
think it's I think it's tough the number
one thing a hard thing to do is to love
yourself I think I think I think we need
to learn at a young age maybe you know
we really need to practice it loving
ourselves and not
you know pointing the finger at
ourselves and saying you know you did
this wrong and you did this wrong
because we have plenty of people saying
that in this town so I don't know I
think it's a daily work
I think it's daily work because I have
those days where I'm like ah you know
you were terrible and then you have
those days really like you were amazing
you know so it's a daily work and I
think it's not just for women I think
it's for men too I think I think we're
all insecure in this town to some degree
in a little bit you know and it's how do
we deal with that how do we try to fill
ourselves up with something positive I
noticed too it seems like there's either
total self-hatred of oneself in this
town or total self-love there's very
little gray area
right it's so true it is it's it is true
it there's a lot of self-hatred or
there's a lot of like way too much
self-love and going on you know and I'm
you're like okay come back down
everybody else um yeah you're right
there is no in-between and I think if we
can find a way to sort of be in that
in-between and have a healthy ego as
well as loving ourselves I think that's
a good combination to have when it comes
to your acting career is there anything
that you do every day no matter what
whether it's look in the mirror and say
I can do this whether it's have cup
coffee what is it that every day you do
no matter what
that helps toward the acting career not
just getting up and being a human but it
helps tour the acting career well I
think keeping sharp in your mind I I do
a lot of like exercises like for
instance before I did this interview or
you know before I do an audition I will
go to a magazine or a book and I'll read
out loud
for like two pages you know and
enunciate every word and push it out
because a lot of the times I was getting
stuck in
you know when I do an audition or I'm
working we're all get stuck in here and
I read daily just to like sort of help
her none CA and I tell other actors it's
a great way before auditions to really
get that Annunciation it's just a read
out loud for you know two or three pages
and you'll feel your mouth getting
warmed up and then you're ready to go
and then you don't have to to worry
about that you know because I would
worry about getting stuck you know
because the fear would get in there or
something like that or you know
auditions are frightening
they are terrifying as an actor I mean
and they're enjoyable too sometimes when
they go well oh but they're terrifying
you know even still like before an
audition I'll get sweaty hands and I'll
have to like talk myself down and it's a
process you know it's not it it's not a
natural process to go in and to subject
yourself to six or seven people in the
room the director the casting director
the producers who are all staring at you
like you know you have to perform and
you hope it goes well but it's it could
be very terrifying so anything that you
can do to alleviate that stress you know
does help so I'll read and then just get
out take my dog for a walk and you know
hang out with all my friends who I have
a great friend base here which is I
think is important when you live in LA
to have good friends because again there
are a lot of people here that will just
want to take and take and take and maybe
not appreciate you for who you are so um
it's important to have good good people
around you mm-hmm
you think being nervous is a good thing
cause I know for me people always say Oh
calm down your unit but I almost think
that that shows than you care sure no I
think absolutely I think if you're not
nervous something's wrong with you you
know I think I think you need to go back
to the table and we assess what's going
on with you if you're not nervous about
this audition
you know then what's going on with you
you should be nervous you know I think
it does it absolutely means that you
care you know you want to put on your
best and you want to you want you want
to doing your best you know but it is
it's it's very nerve-wracking and you
know I get nervous before auditions
still I've been doing this for 22 years
you know before an event before I have
to get up and talk to you you know a big
crowd sure you know there's not again I
don't think we should be complacent or
too relaxed which is interesting because
in our work we have to appear relaxed
you know
but inside just right you have a huge
director looking at you or they've
brought in their main actor to to read
with you you know you got to put that
out of your brain
you know I remember doing an audition
with with Brad Pitt for the Mexican I
got close on a on an audition and my
manager at the time says oh yeah you
could be reading with Brad Pitt so
nonchalantly okay sure
but you have to go in and you have to
put that aside and you know I got to
audition with Brad Pitt and do a scene
and how cool is that how fun is that
so you never know there's a lot of fun
in auditions and you get surprises like
that sometimes where certain actors will
they'll bring them in to read with you
and I didn't end up getting the part but
just being able to go in and read with
somebody that you admire it's you've won
already for me I get nervous and I get
clumsy dude were there ever times when
you got so nervous but you you had to
maybe go for a walk around the block or
yeah yeah usually there's an exercise we
just tense up all of your body just
before an audition you know I'll be in
the waiting room and it's so funny to
walk in to watch other actors do their
thing in the room you know I'm not one
that's very like I did ah today you got
the actors in the room they're saying
their stuff out loud and I'm like don't
do that go outside can't stand that
don't be an actor I just don't you know
what I mean like preserve it go or go
somewhere else you know what I mean
but yeah I'll do something world tense
up your entire body until and then you
let it go and then that like sort of
relax the body or you know whatever you
got to do to sort of relieve that stress
and then a lot of the times that nervous
energy helps because you'll get to the
room and then that'll just propel you
through the scene yeah I did it you know
they're like oh that was amazing and
then you can kind of like okay you could
follow in a little bit more and trust
yourself which is hard to do do you ever
get so nervous that you can't sleep yeah
I'm gonna be a good sleeper I'm not a
very good sleeper and that that over
time here in LA has I went from being a
really good sleeper to I think I don't
know that a lot of people do here I
don't know it's possible but I think
it's a collective sort of energy that
this town has right it's everybody's
trying to like you know so I don't have
a lot of good friends that I I know of
that sleep very well you know yeah I get
nervous especially before an audition
the night before or or like set if I've
got to go to set the next day and work
with you know a major actor and I'm
terrified of getting steamrolled um it
could be very terrifying absolutely and
then you get on set and it's fine and
there but there's always that concern of
getting the part like I'm not going to
be good enough and you have to tell
yourself I have to remind myself you got
the part you know something you did
worked because we'll get it be like I
don't know what I'm doing
you know or you know I've been in that
situation you know the day of and I'm
like I don't know what I'm doing
and you get there and you meet the other
actors and it just falls into place so
yeah but from someone else who has a lot
of trouble sleeping that 4 o'clock in
the morning 3 o'clock in the morning
like that terror that goes through your
mind or any anything you do to kind of
alleviate that because that can be
really scary yeah yeah
man just ride it out ride it out until
you're able to fall back asleep
but I'm the same way I wake up at all
weird times and yeah sleeping and they
are not friends but I'm not really a map
taker either
I just can't fall asleep that easily
well I got so much going on here but
yeah do you read or do you I'd like for
me I'll watch videos on computer coding
and it usually put smoothly but anybody
yeah like learning HTML like these
YouTube videos and it does help but they
are there different things that help you
know I guess I should start watching
these YouTube videos on different
coatings JavaScript yeah yeah it's
fascinating but me asleep right away so
so you'll just go through it you'll just
ready to write it out and you know
hopefully it works out you know and then
once you get on set the adrenaline takes
over and then later on you like you feel
it you know you'll be working on
something and you do a fight scene I
won't feel anything and then later that
night you'll go home and be like oh my
god what have I done to myself because
then it seemed I don't care I'll I'll
I'll do it I'll take a hit I'll do
whatever it takes you know you get your
Adrenaline's going you don't feel it
necessarily until you're taking a shower
and you're like this bruise on this
bruise oh yes yes yes yes I was from
today so what about the paranormal side
of you at like 3:00 in the morning cuz
I've heard that that's very like um
there's like a thing right yeah a lot of
people say away you know at 3:00 a.m.
this is this you know all paranormal
things happen you know why it's the
people say it or what I think people say
it's because number one we're not doing
this right it's the quiet time right
we're not so busy thinking about our
lives and about this usually things are
a little still at that time so we're
able to connect with what's going on
hmm but yes usually after I do a
paranoia event or after I was done
filming go stalkers I would have a very
very hard time falling asleep it's like
a paranormal PTSD actually you know I
would have to like really like sort of
help myself to sleep which was a very
hard process to do because you're
dealing with things that are of not of
this world and energies that we came at
put a put a label on and so it
definitely plays into it and in sleep in
you know and I started uni and of course
the dreams after you've been in these
places are very very visceral and very
real a lot of my dreams actually am in a
haunted location probably for the last
four or five years I'm in a haunted
location trying to get in or out trying
to help people get in or out I don't
know what that is seeing is to help them
cross over I mean if you really wanted
to go maybe maybe that's it I don't know
but just I'm in a haunted location
trying to find my way out or trying to
find my way and so I have no idea what
that I don't dream about acting but
about ghosts about I'll go into a
location and especially when I was doing
this show and then they'll sort of
appear that they'll make themselves I
can see them in my dreams which is very
weird like I'll actually see you know
and I've woke up screaming you know a
lot and wake up and you know the dishes
will be thrown off the cabinets and I
had a nice little scary creature in my
house it was an imp in the imp it's like
a little troll okay so yeah I am I had
this little scream little thing creature
in my house called an end and it was
around the time I was shooting the this
show goes to go stalkers and I had come
home from doing three you know
Asians in two weeks bro we can have
which is crazy
I came back home and I'm sitting on the
couch with my ex-girlfriend at the time
and all of a sudden I I see I see this
big black dot sort of like the size of a
50-cent piece maybe bigger like this
I saw it sort of go all the way across
the back of the couch right and my ex is
sitting here I see this this ball of
black sort of mass come on the back of
the couch like this as soon as I lose
sight of it
my ex-girlfriend she's like this she
picks up on it
sees this thing come down and all of a
sudden it had these long sort of pointy
fingers right and she saw it manifest
from a black ball and it got into these
like long prickly Hanes and then I felt
my shirt go like that it picked up my
shirt it hopped off the couch I heard it
go boom onto the floor and it scurried
into the high room
insane insane and I would see this thing
sort of like crawl off the walls at
night and then I had to do this whole
thing to try to get it out of the house
but um it was interesting because we
both saw it and it manifested into this
thing and it was like it was playing
with me and I felt it pick up the back
of my shirt hop off the couch and scurry
off
they're like little pranksters and is it
is it energy from from a deceased that's
well no I don't think I think that's one
of the otherworldly creatures that we
have the trolls the fairies all these
little things that sort of inhibit
nature so to speak and I think once it
realized that I can hear talk to and I'm
in that world so you know when I
especially after I do an event
I am so keen and picked up on every
little thing it really turns your senses
to what's going on so it was kind of in
that world anyway and
sure enough I mean this thing ran the
back of my couch it's very intelligent
and me both sides so that's one of many
things that happens in my house has been
pretty quiet for a while which has been
nice because there are times when my dog
doesn't sleep you know have a little
little dog Lima and she's sort of my
barometer because she'll look and see
something or she'll back away or I'll
watch her eyes go from one person to
another which is quite insane but that
hasn't happened in a while yeah well
here's something scurry along the carpet
and it'll end up in the kitchen and you
hear that is right it's crazy crazy are
you able to turn it off yeah oh yeah
it's hard thing to turn off it's a
really hard thing to turn off I I had I
had done an investigation where it was a
really not so nice place and my energy
change right away I was with a buddy and
I got angry and I got home and I was
pacing back and forth and I sort of had
attached or not I didn't attach but some
spirits had attached themselves to me
followed me back in my place and they
caused havoc in my place for a while so
it was a real process to actually get to
sleep at night knowing about my dog is
freaking out I had to like hold her
close because she's freaking out about
what she's saying and they're like right
there but I just standing right there
you can feel their presence or I'll wake
up and Lima will be across my chest and
she'll be she'll be rigid and she bigger
or that low growl staring just right to
the next me like this
things like that happen but it you know
makes it interesting I don't really like
that stuff in my home you know what I
mean but it's it's it's a it's part of
the game I think if you go out and you
open yourself up to some degree and I
feel like I have sort of a fun nature so
these spirits are like yeah he's a
Disneyland let's go hang out with him
you sort of have to talk them out you
have to say you know this is your home
like if you're at somewhere in a haunted
place you say this is your home you have
to stay here you cannot come back home
with me
and then over time it'll sort of
dissipate those sort of go wherever they
need to go back home
maybe they'll you know cross over which
is a question that you asked do people
know like some spares know that they're
dead and the question the answer is no
I've had I've had I've been on a device
before it's called a spirit box it's a
modified radio that scans different
radio frequencies and it causes a white
noise for you to be able to talk to
spirits in real time and I said do you
know that you're dead and then I heard a
woman come through she goes I am and the
way she said it was so sad
and she had no idea and so maybe just
maybe she heard that it was like aah and
then she went off and joined I have no
idea I would like to think there's
something beyond this or else what the
hell yeah or else what the hell I mean
this love has to mean something and if
we can't carry that over somewhere and
love the people that we loved on this
life then I know I love how this is
getting so like deep and you know we're
going back between acting and this but I
think it all plays into life so with
your work as a paranormal investigator
just some people have trouble accepting
it believing it do they had a fearful of
it yes I I think if somebody somebody
says yes to a certain experience that
they had
then they have to they may have to go in
there and reassess everything that they
believe and that can be too scary for
people sometimes I think of it as a gift
I think of it when something happens to
me that you can't explain it's a gift
when I first started doing this I was at
an investigation at the Linda Vista
Hospital in Los Angeles
that's an old abandoned hospital check
it out it's a pretty cool spot during
this investigation
I had asked and I said well what's in
this room and then you hear through the
box it goes a demon right whether or not
that's true or not who knows but I went
home that night it was actually the next
day and exco a friend of mine goes babe
did you get scratched and like where is
it she's like on your neck like it's
been burning actually so I went and I
look tonight looked into the mirror and
sure enough there were three scratches
on my neck two of them went this way and
then one went this way
so whatever scratched me had this weird
sort of like effed up claw right and it
was like a hypodermic needle scratch so
I can scratch myself like this all day
long it's not gonna make that thin
hypodermic needle sort of scratch and
sure enough there were three of them in
a burn unlike anything else they burned
right and they stayed there for probably
good three or four days and I was sort
of the beginning of me a lot of people
would be like oh I'm never doing that
again and I was like no I felt like
whatever touched me
we connected in some weird way whatever
it was and that kind of like led me on
this whole crusade and I and and you
know when something happens like that it
makes you ask those deeper questions
well what was that what was it that
scratched me I don't know but I want to
go and try to figure it out do you do
you want to help these entities or are
you just interested in just being
present and having them speak to you um
I absolutely go into it with with it all
depends on your intention so some people
will go in there and puff up
chest and say I'm gonna kick your ass
come do something to me you know and
then you might get your ass handed to
you in some in some way I always go in
and say I'm here at a love and respect
it's your intention and not not always
is going to protect you but it's your
intention and I feel like they sense
that they know it's funny they'll know
your name before you walk in somewhere I
feel like you know I I said Do You Know
Who I am and nine times out of ten
they'll say Chad Chad Chad you know
whatever did you know we're gonna be
here yes did you have a hand in bringing
us here yes so I don't know what it is I
you know possibly and these are all my
my sort of speculations and when I've
gathered from people that I've worked in
this industry that maybe we have this
sort of like this energy that sort of
beams out of us right and spirits are
able to go in there and decode it like
pick out like things that are like and
be able to know things about that they
couldn't possibly know no no no I it
reminds me of some things I won't go
into but yeah yeah I've talked to Dave
about certain things it's it's hard to
talk to other people about it though
because people get scared of it yeah
right people do get scared and that's
okay it is scary I mean before I would
go into these places especially on the
show I'm terrified I'm absolutely 110%
terrified I would call my mom before I
walked in these places you know during
during the show be like I love you you
know I mean I felt like my life was in
danger
you know because you're just you can't
pretty you can't anticipate you know
what you're coming up against and maybe
that's why I like it because on set I
know what's coming man I know
everybody's lines you know but this it's
like you know it's completely whole
different kind of theory yeah that's
interesting that it is such a different
thing because it's totally unexpected
whereas the set is controlled very
controlled
you know you might not wear and know
where their scene is going or how the
act is going to be but you know you know
it's probably gonna head in the lines
and what not doing the paranormal all
walking I don't know what's gonna happen
you know but I know it's going to I do
it because it teaches me something about
life and about myself and and again
there's so much weird things in this
world that we don't give credit to why
not go out and explore it and try to
have a weird experience I mean I think
we all can sort of go back in our brain
and be like well is this one time there
was this one time everybody's got a
story in there but a lot of people are
afraid to acknowledge it because it
means they have to sort of go in there
and open up a different way so to other
actors find that other thing that really
moves you that may be just like a
complete opposite of what the business
is absolutely I I think yes find
something we have a lot of passions I
don't think you know we can just have
one passion you know and and for me
acting definitely is a passion of mine
is Who I am
but I found something that that fulfills
me just as much in a whole different way
and challenges me in a whole different
way so I think you know assess what your
passions are and go after them because
the acting is not always going to be
consistent I think you know anyone here
that lives here in this town knows that
so whether you know if you're an artist
draw I mean do something creative and in
the meantime or investigate ghosts like
I do and call it good
what is your product or your brand what
is the brand of Chad Limburg good
question well again I think these days
were especially able to to brand
ourselves with you know Twitter Facebook
all of these social media aspects you
know I guess I don't ever look at myself
as a brand but I guess I am to some
degree because I'm selling myself and a
lot of you know I'm chatting a bargain
and what comes with that you know the
acting and the paranormal and you know
especially these days it is important I
think to promote yourself to use the
social media aspect and and my brand is
me Chad Lindberg whatever that entails
that day you know generally I'm a
happy-go-lucky guy and and I love people
and I love interacting with my fans and
I call them friends actually I'm not a
big fan not a big fan of the word of
fans home I called them my friend and
you know a lot of these people I've met
through the years through Twitter and
all this social media I've gotten jobs
because of social media because of
supernatural they had killed me spoiler
alert they had killed me on season two
and then Twitter came along and I sort
of led this revolt on Twitter and said
let's make some noise and get Ash back
on the show and people wrote letters
they made posters they made videos and
the producers got wind of that and
actually had me back on the show this is
kind of like in the beginning of Twitter
so nowadays like you know okay who cares
you know but it works it works and it
was the power of fans number one and
that the power of the fandom I mean the
supernatural fandom is insanely loyal
and and and and just awesome and I'm so
blessed to have them so I guess you know
I guess the brand is is me whatever
whatever Chad
that day and I try to be honest with
people you know if I'm not feeling good
that day I'll let people know I don't
like to fake it you know I like to sort
of let people know exactly what's going
on with me and if and if I'm not feeling
great great that day then probably not a
good time to be on social media and to
take a break you know don't you be angry
angry what are some of the things that
you'll say to just let people know you
know what maybe today is just gonna be a
quiet day for me I just won't say
anything I just won't get on social
media but there are days when I'm
feeling awful and you guys still have
something that you got to promote so you
know typically those days I'll just sort
of like tweet something and not get on
periscope or anything that people will
get to see me you know and look into my
eyes and say oh maybe he's not doing too
well today so you know I try to keep it
honest do you feel pressured to get back
to people because I know you know you
want to say thank you and I think I've
seen you a couple of times thank people
yeah when I've checked in on your
Twitter so do you feel pressure to make
sure that everybody feels heard from um
not so much I I mean I get a lot of
tweets and a lot of people writing
questions or you know on snapchat and it
would be impossible to catch everybody
it's just impossible but I try I try
especially on Twitter you know I'll
spend a good hour sometimes just saying
hi to people you know and I tell a lot
of other actors in this industry you
know the social media is just as
important now is you know getting the
job you know we have to sort of it comes
hand in hand and it does help it'll help
you get back on a show or you know
you've got something coming up and you
want everyone to go see it well social
media allows people now to catch wind of
something that you're doing or it's it's
really important tool I know you've done
a lot of panels or like comic-con or
different ones so will you tweet about
going somewhere and then you see people
show up yeah absolutely yeah I do a lot
of supernatural conventions a lot of
conventions in general or if I'm doing
investigations I want people to show up
you know say I'm gonna be here and then
you see those people show up it's
it's an amazing thing I love social
media you know sometimes it can be a
little bit of a you know you got your
trolls on there and you've got the
haters and whatnot but I always say if
you've got the lovers and the haters
that you're doing something right yeah
Chad do you find that most Hollywood
actors are competitive or actresses yeah
I think this is a very competitive town
and I think we do have a lot of
competition out there but again I always
say this again to other actors that ask
me I say the competition is really with
yourself that's it you're competing with
you at the end of the day it's you yes
you're gonna have actors that you come
against and maybe you're gonna lose that
role well that role was not meant to be
yours I think a role is so personal that
it goes to the person that it's meant to
go to you know do I think anybody get
else could play - one supernatural no
you know what I mean am i right for this
movie that Edward Norton got no that's
him it's it's it's a very personal thing
a role so I I think that the the
competition is with you you need to be
able to step up and do it and believe
that you're gonna be the one that's
going to get the job and it might not go
your way and it just wasn't meant to be
and that's how I deal with it it's like
all right it's not meant to be so it's
not my role but you have to go through
all those auditions in order to get that
one part and you may know I mean I know
most of the time I'm probably not gonna
get this this is not the guy they're
looking for but you go in and you have
to take that step in order to get to the
job that you're gonna get maybe five six
maybe ten twenty auditions down the road
you have to do it was this always your
mindset or did it evolve over time yeah
I think it evolved over time I've been
lucky in that my career has gone very
step by step by step by step by step
frustrating at times because I just want
to be like yeah you go here and
we'll be great and I don't think it
works that way I've had friends go from
here to here really really fast and that
must you know with with their brain I
think III yeah I've been very lucky and
that I've had a slow burn in this
business and and I've worked a lot and
have done things that have been very
recognizable so I feel blessed that I've
sort of been kept in check along the way
and taken those proper steps and been
able to have a healthy perspective about
it
22 years later back when I was younger
it was just like you know you're going
and you just have no idea and like I
said I put on the blinders and I just go
nowadays you know you sort of like take
off the blinders do but like alright you
got a you know you know I know I don't
know I'm trying to say yeah yeah yeah
you gotta have a healthy perspective and
keep it all in check you know because we
can you know I think you lose a little
bit of reality when we're you know start
spending that money that we have even
God the job yet or we're you know what I
mean just got to keep it in check and
then and even when you get the job you
just gotta like keep in check also too
then you found the love or the love for
paranormal investigation was enhanced
and maybe if it had been Tuni projects
all at once you wouldn't have had time
to see that I don't know right right
putting words in your mouth well right
yeah if it happened too fast then you
know in a lot you know again I did get a
lot of big things in the in the
beginning of my career I don't know if
it happens too fast I think I think you
could be in a lot of trouble and
everybody's everybody's timing is
different you know what I mean you could
be ten years old and be nominated for an
act you know for Best Best Actor and or
and that's when you're a moment arrives
or you could be 48 have your moment
arrive or you can be you know like Bryan
Cranston who has been working for years
and years and years and years right
great acted not many people really knew
who he was and then he got malcolm in
the middle' right and then Breaking Bad
came along and now who doesn't know who
in crimson is you know he's an older guy
and he had his moment you know his big
big moment with Breaking Bad so it's
like you just don't know you know and so
you just keep plugging away and you just
don't give up and just keep believing
how important do you think it is for an
actor to know who they are you talked
about turning 40 and feeling like you
know who you are you feel comfortable do
you think people 40 50 60 all of them
know that no no well I think we're
always learning and and the moment we
say we know who we are then I can
probably come tomorrow I'll be like I
have no idea who I am I have no idea
what's going on what is happening again
I think having a healthy perspective
having good family you know we're
friends definitely helped keep you
grounded having a dog it keeps agree you
know you need things to keep you
grounded and in this industry I think
you need to know what works for you you
need to know what your wheelhouse is you
know again when I first got down here I
was shooting after after meeting man
roles and I'm gonna be the leading man
and I would get close but then they
wouldn't cast me because I'm not what
they were looking for physically I can
give them what they were looking for an
energy wise but not physically so you
know it took me a while to be okay with
being the geek in these particular roles
or or being a this guy and and and then
realizing you know I'm in a good spot
being a being where I'm at because I can
go a million different ways I feel like
you know I'm not I'm not
pigeon holed into one particular
character or look so I mean it's
interesting that you see yourself as as
a geek and maybe you don't I don't see
you as that I see you more as the
leading man and I'm sure there's a lot
of women and probably men too that would
um do you ever feel pressure and I think
I asked you this earlier but just
to be sort of this this guy that's
people look up to and that they find
attractive
I hadn't put anyone know no but but do
you feel that pressure because if you if
someone doesn't see themselves that way
but the outside world maybe does maybe
one casting director here didn't or this
person didn't but right maybe other
people do do you ever feel isn't it a
weird sort of a thing because other
people see you maybe in a different
light right you are more than man I
appreciate that thank you I again I feel
like any one spot right now it it's okay
I again I feel like I grew into myself
you know when I first got here I looked
like I was 12 now is 19 and and I did
fit into more of the geek and there's
nothing wrong I am a geek at heart I you
know I'm a serious geek at heart and
maybe that's why I play so many because
I just I you know I am a geek at heart
but yes there you know there's a lot of
pressure in this town and you know for
four years
you know this industry makes you very
aware of how you look and and and you
know how you perceived and for a while I
was very self-conscious about my chin
and for years I was always very
self-conscious about it and I could
never figure out why and I would do a
profile shot I'd be like oh my god I was
so self-conscious about this even as a
young boy and then I got to LA and it
was sort of you know after going out and
I was sort of in the pinnacle of like
trying to find who I was and and it was
sort of suggested to me that well I
remember asking somebody in this
business well why why am I not getting
these roles and they were like this and
it was like it was so detrimental to me
I was like no it's true like it's true
they okay it's true like it is my chin
you know and it was something that just
bothered me for years it's just it just
bothered me and then I stuff it right
and I was gonna I was going to get a a
chin enhancement
I was gonna get a surgery at the time
and this was like back in the days of
Maslin so it was back in 97 98 99 and so
I had gone and gotten a loan and I was I
saw this doctor here in Los Angeles and
okay I was gonna do it I was gonna get a
chin implant and here we go I was gonna
be taken seriously and then my friends
at the time talked me out of it and I'm
glad I did and it was something I really
at that time found out who I was without
the chain with how anything and I really
came into my own and felt like okay I
Know Who I am
and then over time I stuffed still stuff
that insecurity down deep down until it
sort of came out one night when I
playing a board game with my family
something questioned about the looks and
I said something about my chin and I was
really defensive about it and then my
fam was like why don't you just do it
and I'm like yeah well maybe it's okay
maybe it's okay if I you know this is
something I feel like I need to do
within myself so fast forward however
many years ago I forget maybe this was
like six seven years ago I went home to
a family doctor and I got a chin implant
and no one would be able to to tell they
just put like a little sort of slit here
and they just kind of slid this little
implant here and then when it was done I
felt like oh okay this is how I felt
inside the whole time but my outer never
really fit this way and then I got the
the chin implant I got the surgery done
and it's actually in the my big big
break documentary and from that day
forth from that day on I've never
questioned it I've never been like oh I
got a chin it just felt like okay now my
face feels like it always should have
and it gave me a confidence inside of
myself that wasn't there before and and
and so and I and I say this because a
lot of actors in this town do things to
themselves to alter their looks in a
certain way and that's something that's
a reality of this
business and more often than not most
people have had something done and I
talk about it and I'm very honest about
it and it's in the movie in my big break
where they actually show the doctor
doing the surgery on me and me waking up
and so many people lie about it and it's
their own thing it's it's their own if
you don't want to tell people it's okay
but I wanted to tell people because it
is a it's a thing in this industry and I
say whatever makes you feel better if it
makes you feel better and it helps you
know your confidence then go for it you
know I'm saying and then there are some
people that maybe take it to the hilt
and just do way too much because they're
trying to feed an insecurity that cannot
fill you know what I mean you have to go
within but this was one thing that made
me feel like me so yeah I think there is
a pressure absolutely and it's how you
deal with it and it's how you find
yourself and but at the end of the day
you have to do something for you
and that's why I did it was for me it
wasn't it wasn't for this industry it
was not her acting I had gotten past
that it wasn't it wasn't for anybody in
this town it was for me and once I did
it I felt great and I haven't really
thought about it since after the surgery
did people treat you differently no no
which is good which is good they didn't
treat me differently I may be treated
myself differently I'm I probably I'm
not as um you know if I I'm not as
self-conscious about my profile you know
that was something even I was a boy
which at a young age you really
shouldn't have any sort of like
perception of your body and being secure
like that but I was I remember being
very insecure about my profile and then
when it was brought to my attention here
in town I'm like oh god it's it's true
it's all very true but after doing it I
felt so much better and I felt more
confident and myself and no one treated
me differently you know and and and not
many people know you know unless they've
seen the movie they like live
couldn't even tell I'm like well yeah
that was the whole point you know and I
have a really had a really good doctor
who wanted to make it so subtle that it
wasn't a thing you know and then you
wake up you have that moment we're like
oh my god I look different you know you
had to go through that whole thing and
then you sort of settle into your new
look so to speak I had before and after
pictures and it made a huge difference
and sort of I think you know maybe it'll
make it the difference later on about
playing a leading man sort of role and
I'm never going to be this sort of
leading man that is the great thing
these days it's leaning man has sort of
changed into this it's not you know the
typical or they could looking guy now he
could be more interesting people which i
think is what people want to see it's
more interesting people people that
could they can relate to but maybe this
makes a difference maybe it doesn't but
for me it made a huge difference so it
sounds like it was more internal than it
was really where it made the difference
yeah it was it was very much internal
and it was something that I had I had
stuffed down and it would create such an
anger inside of me until I heard that it
was okay and it was always okay my
parents and the family always supported
it but once they said hey just do it I
was like oh yeah maybe I should maybe I
should talk to Tony and it was a bit
about it and they supported it so you
know yeah again it's it's it's
unfortunately the looks department is a
bottomless pit here in Los Angeles and I
think if you could sort of keep a middle
ground don't go too crazy you know keep
who you are but just maybe you know do
the things that you got to do to make
yourself feel better if some people have
trouble taking compliments and then some
people they can't take enough
compliments about them there they're
busy giving their own compliments of on
the road how has that been for you to
come into your own whatever it is you
peace that you've come to be with
yourself how is that to accept
compliment
because I'm sure there's people let's
not talk about the trolls because they
always exist or anything but but people
that do give you genuine compliments
whether it's about your looks your
performance your ghost hunting right
right right I you know I take I think
compliments I don't know
yeah again like there are people that
just want to hear themselves being a
door left and right and I think they got
a real issue I think they got a problem
and I think that's a scary place to be
in you know I think I think if that's
the case you are so insecure and you
need to find something inside of you
that's real because I you know on the
flip side I think I think it's hard to
take compliment sometimes I know I guess
it falls back into loving yourself and
being okay with taking compliments and
and again I'm always so humbled by
compliments and I take it to heart
because it means a lot to me and these
are people that again in my lives and
these in the friends like fans whatever
you know I just I feel very lucky to get
those compliments so I take them very
seriously and to heart when you walk
into an audition what are you telling
yourself even if you think I have this
idea about who this character is and I
don't think I'm gonna get it but I'm
just still I'm gonna still show up and
try to do what I can
what do I tell myself what do you do are
you giving yourself any kind of a talk
or no each each situation is totally
different
I don't think for me it talks really
help in that instance you know if I have
an audition that day you're thinking
okay especially if it's at 5:00 p.m.
which I hate the auditions because you
have to hold on to that all day drives
me crazy I like a good early audition in
the morning let's get it done you know
cuz it's tough you got to hang on to
that all day
I think preparation is is key you know a
talk for me won't do me because I'm so
nervous and I'm like shut up Chad I
don't want to hear your oh just
go in and do it and I think you just got
to go in there and do it you got to be
prepared I you know I like to if I'll
have my sides here I will I will
memorize the whole entire thing
especially if it's like the next day and
one thing I do to sort of help that
actors pay attention it's really a great
thing every phone now has a voice
recorder right so I will go and I'll
take the sides and I'll read every line
even if it's not my line I will read the
entire scene out loud at a very monotone
voice and then I'll replay that over and
over and over again and you go in the
next day and they'll be memorized so I
think preparation will take away sort of
any anxiety that you had well you should
be anxious and nervous but it's going to
take away that that extra moment of fear
because look we've all actors some of
some sometimes we don't prepare as much
as we should and we've gone in we've all
been there we've all been there and um
you know you you you get cold honey you
know you go in there and you've been
doing your thing and you loose your
place and you've got to go back and it's
awful you know your face turns red and
then it's like and you know that
instance you're like I'm not getting
this this just went out the door so you
got to be prepared and it's tough to do
because sometimes you'll get an audition
for the next day and you'll get another
one and you get another one you've got
three the next day and they're all 15
pages long and they want to see you be
seen so you know you gotta you gotta be
willing to do that work Chad I know you
said that you've made a decision to have
your life as an actor and whatever ups
and downs that brings but do you look at
your career as a business yes I do think
that it's a business they call it was a
show business not show friends
it's a business it's a very hard
business but it's very rewarding too if
you're able to break in and and do some
of the great projects that I've done I
feel very lucky but there is a business
that comes with it you got to make hard
decisions sometimes you have to part
ways with you know your agent or your
manager or somebody that you've built a
relationship with and you have to move
on and those are the worst conversations
to have they are awful especially me I I
take I take I take everything to heart
and I just don't take any relationship
granted for granted so yeah there are
hard choices and it it is a business
however if you can if you can focus on
your creativity and remind yourself of
why you're doing it and and the love
that you have for it the business part
so it's going to be there but it won't
become I don't think it should become
the main focus I think we should focus
on our creativity and then yeah we got
we got to play the game too
have you ever had a friendship or an
acquaintance sour because they felt
intimidated maybe they felt like their
accomplishments didn't measure up with
yours yeah I've had I've had friends
yeah failure is a funny thing that dead
that gets sort of on the way of
friendships all the friendships I've had
have you should be happy for your for
your friends because their success is my
success my success is your success on
the same way on on Twitter and Instagram
like I'll boost up my friends and
hopefully they'll do the same for me I
mean that's why we're doing this we have
to lift each other up I've had friends
I've had a friend take his own life
because he didn't think he was good
enough I was somebody that I worked with
in this town
and it's a reminder of again where this
place can take you if you're not you
know if you don't reach out and sort of
be like hey you know you're not the only
one that's feeling this stuff so it's
I've seen it go tons of different ways
I've seen friends you know succeed I've
seen friends move back home I've seen
friends
unfortunately pass on and you know it
happens you know it's it's a really hard
industry and and I again and I'll go
back to the guy today who wanted me to
get him into the business man you got to
be 110 percent about this business or
don't don't do it because it's it's just
so hard and but it's who you are then I
can't imagine doing anything else
so then pursue it yeah if you if you
can't imagine doing anything else and we
should absolutely pursue it and see
where it goes take a risk take a chance
you know I think that's why we're here
on this earth is to take chances what if
you learned about making money as an
actor and if that's too personal no no
no no these I try to get my mom what
have you learned about making money as
an actor that it comes and goes very
quickly too quickly sometimes the the
main misconception that people have is
that actors are rich that we live you
know lavishly and some do some do you
know I think a very small percentage do
but you know for the majority of us
working actors you know we'll have a
little income come in and then it's gone
the next minute and it's tough you know
even at this point in my career it's
still hard and people like oh you're
rich and you're no I'm not I'm really
not again you know I'm not I'm not
season 10 on a series that's been going
on for years
you know I am NOT so-and-so that's
making twenty million dollars a picture
it just doesn't picture what am I like
back in the day is now I'm going on
pictures I think we should go back to
Connaughton pictures yeah but yeah the
most common misconception is that we're
rich and that's just not the case and
you know you know I'll find any other
way to bring that money in and thank God
there are residuals that keep us alive
you know and I found other ways to bring
an income but it's tough man and I would
say you know hang on to your money if
you get it and even I have a problem
with that you know because there's no
there's no study there's not a steady
job you know what I mean so it's like
when it comes in you feel like you got
to enjoy you know because you don't know
when it's gonna come next and even at
this age I have to learn to to hang on
to it's because you just don't know when
it's going to when you're gonna get paid
again and it could be you could get paid
very well or you know not get paid and
you got to respect the money yeah it's
funny if you do a search a Google search
on just any famous person or a
well-known person those like the drop
down suggestions and so it'll it'll
suggest you know whether the person is
married or not and then in evitable a
like the third thing is net worth it's
just so funny that everybody wants to
know it you know right Chad being a
person of interest being a celebrity
whatever label or non label you want to
put on it there's always gonna be people
online that are going to say different
things and I have to say that I saw
something that said death rumor and I
was like what I mean yeah so how do you
how do you handle something like that
that's it was a little eerie at first
because a buddy of mine brought it to my
attention like a couple years ago and
there's this website that does - rumors
you know their net worth is like 30
million dollars and that couldn't be
further from the truth and and then one
was like Chad Lunenburg was killed in a
car crash and I read it and it felt
eerie I was like oh my god I didn't like
that feeling at all it was like I don't
know it just put that energy into the
area like like my possibly could die or
maybe what is it you know it's it's just
a very weird thing and people like to
stir up crap on the Internet and you
know and I don't do these to these
websites I think it's funny to do this
or if they make money on it
piss off piss off with your death rumors
and stuff like that because people take
that seriously you know what if my mom
or my sister happened to come across
that and even though I told them about
it with them out - it's like yeah that's
not cool you know I don't know why
people think it's funny to do something
like that or to spread a rumor online
that someone has passed some day that's
going to be a reality it's not very
funny you know I think you know again
we're dealing with people that don't
have much time on their hands
or these websites that want to benefit
off of you know celebrity and making up
these false rumors and that's where we
get into trouble you know I mean right
well I've seen it done to a lot of
people and I guess maybe in some ways if
you had to look at it in any way that's
positive well at least you have a name
that people have right exactly yeah
exactly
I guess they and they are concerned
about whether or not that's a good thing
and now it's it's funny because now I
had talked to the dead yeah right so
your so since you're so close to that
world how was it to see that or maybe
you weren't doing the investigation I
was yeah
okay what you know I again doing the
paranormal and experiencing the things
that I do really makes you ask those
questions and it makes you realize just
how fragile this is I mean on a daily
basis I'm just like you see someone get
an accident where someone passes away
and you're like why why did that have to
happen why did someone so have to pass
away like why did someone so I have to
go the way they did you know I don't
know I don't know so it's a reminder
that we should just appreciate every
moment that we have because we just
don't know what's the biggest audition
you've ever had
Wow the biggest audition I've ever had a
good question and I would say the
October sky audition I had was no you
you went from the casting director and
then the director and then I got the
screen test which a screen test is
always interesting because they put you
up in the clothes and the outfits and
they actually film you doing this scene
and you've got two other actors that are
hoping to get the same part and they
come up and they dress them up you know
identical to you and and you get rid of
really clothes since I ended up getting
the movie and then it worked out and
then you think about the other two guys
that showed up on set and went through
the whole rigmarole you got to sign the
paperwork and everything it doesn't
happened so you definitely feel the
stakes you know are pretty high and then
an interesting sort of audition story
that I tell a lot again this is
something I learned when The Fast and
the Furious audition came my way again
where I was at in my time at that time
in my life I didn't realize what I had I
was off in my own sort of thinking about
what I thought about the business I got
the audition and it was called red line
action
at the time and I I remember passing on
the audition and why because I just
didn't wanna I had in my mind I wanted
to do something completely different
with my life at the time again maybe 23
years old you know so I got the audition
I passed got the audition twice I passed
right my agent at the time calls me up
and says what are you doing like you
really want to pass on this and I said
yeah I mean I was just being a little
punk just like fine hung up the phone on
me I'm like yeah right
my mom making decision decisions another
agent from the same agency called me up
and he said you know come on go in and
I'm like okay I'll go in I was being a
brat I was being a brat and I Wayne
Isham and I met the director Rob Cohen
he's very friendly and so nice and the
casting director who I love and so I
auditioned and and they liked what I did
and then they called me back or they
want me to come back and be with a
couple of the other actors and so I'm
like and then you started like sort of
play it in your mind like oh oh you like
me okay you know all right yeah yeah
I'll go back here yeah sure so I go in
and I'd read with whether he was Matt
Schulze at the time and I'm Johnny
strong I believe and they were trying to
fit like the guys that you know cuz they
already had you know Paul and VIN and
everybody and I ended up booking this
movie I got the part and I'm like wow
this is really cool and we're gonna do
all these cars and then we got on set
and it became you know this crazy thing
and everyone's gonna be like oh it's
gonna be it's gonna be huge it's gonna
be this big moving I'm like no I just
don't I don't I don't think so I was
just so locked into this into this brain
of mine and then lo and behold it became
like a huge phenomenon and it changed my
life instantly and it taught me I can
that you never never never no don't
don't turn down an audition don't don't
be silly you know and I was really silly
and I tell this story and not that I was
so appreciative that I went in and I was
given that opportunity andand ah it
changed my life forever forever so I
learned a valuable lesson then you know
just you know keep your mind open you
know appreciate what you have if it
comes when you're 19 if it comes when
you're 40 just appreciate that moment so
what were you hoping for at 23 what what
type of role would you have thought was
more I mean I realize it's a lot of
actors they're not maybe at that time
and then they see what it is later but
what were you what what kind of gets at
that time I wanted to do something edgy
and hardcore yeah I just wanted to do
something just Quito I didn't I you know
and maybe it was again it was the
computer geek you know it was like
computer geek Jesse yeah you know and it
was like in my mind maybe I was sort of
like pushing away those characters
because I would just keep getting a
computer guy computer this computer this
and it drove me crazy you know so maybe
that also played a part in that was just
sort of like pushing that away but no
I'm not that guy I want to do something
crazy and swear and and be a crazy weird
guy and you know when it again when it's
your part it's a very personal thing and
it will find you it will find you and
I'm so lucky that it did because again
that movie has now become you know
they're working on number eight and it's
like you know again people recognize me
from it every day and they tell me how
much that movie means to them and how
many times they've seen it and so I'm
like again I've been very lucky so
alright yeah you just never know did you
ever drive for your own white Jetta no
and they barely let us drive in the
movie too because you just don't give
actors cars on set we got to drive a
little bit and then they would put us in
picture cars which was great and the
scene where I'm racing
you trying they they had tied up my car
it was a picture car they tied it up to
a semi and they hauled me like a 70 80
miles per hour and they put an actual
car from my eyeline racing next to me so
when I'm driving like this it's you're
actually like racing somebody not for
real but you know there it can complete
control
obviously the cameras are on the you
know the bed of the truck and whatnot so
but yeah I'm looking back man I mean so
cool just you know I wish to do I want
to do something like that now and have
the sort of the greater appreciation and
the the majestical scope that I have now
about this business and what it means I
think that would be a huge thrill you
know to go back and sort of do something
like that that has such a again again
you just never know the movies that you
think are gonna be huge no not so much
in the movies you think I don't know it
turned out to be phenomenons so yeah
well it's the beauty of being 23 is that
you don't sometimes realise what's being
given you know I think right there's a
beauty to that - yeah absolutely and I
had no idea and that taught me a lot you
know so going back to October Sky where
were you in your life when you have that
audition what was your mind I was a
barely 21 years old I had just turned 21
uh-huh I was in sort of the same mindset
I remember being on set and thinking and
that was my that was I don't even know
it and I love this interview because it
makes me reflect and it makes me go back
and sort of re appreciate you know the
things that I've gone through and been
through and and that have worked out you
know it's scary to think what if it
didn't work out where would I be what
would I be doing so I was a fresh 21 and
you know I'm now I'm on set with with
all of these picture cars and it was in
his time period you know we're telling
this true story about Homer Hickam and
the Rocket Boys and Jake Gyllenhaal was
he was 16 I think at the time he was
being still he headed to school on set
you know and when will the Scott and I
were the two oldest and and again we had
the the only thing to do and and
Tennessee was the 24-hour Walmart and
that's how we kept ourselves busy and
you know I remember the studio is
sending us Playstations
you know we first got the part and we're
like these kids and like oh you're
sending us like Playstations and like
all of a sudden you're just being thrown
all these opportunities and it's it's
again when you're when you're young and
you don't realize it but that was one of
the greatest times ever
well most pure just you know when you're
that age too you're not really thinking
about all the adult stuff that has to
come into play you know that we worry
about much later on
we're just free and had fun so you know
and we just had they just did a Rocket
Boys festival that I just attended not
too long ago for his anniversary I guess
15 15 years 15 years know like that was
fast and furious probably longer I don't
know now that all these anniversaries it
just reminds me of how much I've been in
this industry but but yeah it's cool to
see where all these projects go and what
they become and so 40 a young 40 thank
you
I play a lot younger but what would you
like to see yourself doing I would love
to play an alien much like Star Man
which I've Jeff Bridges back in the day
over my all-time favorite movies I want
to play an alien that comes to earth and
then falls in love that whole typical
story that we've seen a million times
but I've always wanted to play an alien
I don't know I think I would be a really
good alien yeah or a monster my play a
villain but like a you know a famous
villain of some sort I don't know I
don't know I want to play a a lien you
heard it here first
alien Oh what is it about because I
would I could envision you're playing
something well I mean it's still
supernatural yes yeah yes oh yeah but
what is it about the
was it about Starman I don't know you
know I don't know I just loved those
sort of those movies about about the
about an alien or that movie powder you
know just something that you know when
the character is something supernatural
or I don't know I've just always loved
those alien comes to earth story isn't
trying to figure out how to go home and
falls in love in the process and I've
always I don't know I always want to
play an alien and persecuted but really
a good guy but really a good guy
yeah xenophobic they don't know who
exactly yeah but told in a very simple
level I think these days it's like this
grandiose CGI and stuff like that and
and let's just go back to their
relationship and this story I just know
I'm all about the aliens and the ghosts
and the the weird stuff in this world
man and I want to tap into that and and
play it why do you think you resonate
with weirder characters because I'm
weird yeah I don't know I've always I
always play a little bit left you know I
mean I'm boys playing off-kilter I have
the hardest time playing simple I have a
hard time playing just a regular guy
it's hard for me I'll go in and try to
like always make it a little bit more
interesting or I'm just sort of
off-kilter guy in a good way it's kind
of what I can bring to the table if
people say child Lindenberg well you can
you know come in and be weird you know
do my thing so maybe that's why I'm
always attracted to I just don't like
normal
I don't like normal I've never been a
fan of a normal whatever new normal
means
I think normal scary but were you always
that accepting of the weird label cuz I
know like in high school no one wants to
get that label right everyone wants to
be part of like the N group right but
then I think as you get older you
realize I kind of have seen the in-group
it's it's kind of too boring
yeah the in-group was never
something I strived for in high school I
was cool with everybody because I was
the weird guy I was the weird funny guy
you know everybody just knew could laugh
at you know I was the guy I was making
jokes and got up on stage and I wanted
to entertain people so I was to go to
weird guy I still am but I you know
we're did a good sense not weird like
not John winking yeah exactly
just just weird fun yeah yeah
comfortable being comfortable with
yourself exactly I've always been pretty
comfortable with me and I guess that's
why I became an actor it's because I
knew I'm weird I can make this work for
me so here I am
Chad we have a quote here from someone
which is an unlikely person to go for
acting but it's from David Bowie and I
just found it the other day I thought it
was interesting and the quote said as
you get older questions come down to
about two or three things how long and
what do I do with the time that I have
left and the reason this kind of stuck
out to me was I'm just thinking about it
my own life yeah so I'm just wondering
for you does this bring up anything
interesting just because you know life
changes after the 20s and this is yeah I
just turned 40 and so that question
definitely looms Siple how much longer
how am I going to go what more do I have
to do here there's a lot to do
I feel like 40 is the new 20 maybe I
don't know you know it makes me reflect
on all of my time that I've that I've
spent in Los Angeles and pursuing an
acting career and I look back and I'm
like thank God because when you're young
you don't really realize what you're
getting into you know and I kind of had
my blinders on and I'm like well nothing
is gonna get here I'm gonna go and do it
and I'm very lucky that it happened
because it doesn't happen for a lot of
people so 22 years in I'm like but it's
still just as hard as it was okay well I
mean you're incredibly young 40 thank
you thank you sign yeah yeah now do you
think maybe there'll be new rules maybe
not
Jessie or maybe Jessie reinvent it right
but but now there's a whole new thing
open to you as a 40 year old male right
you could still pass for a way younger
by right knowing I appreciate that I
can't do high school team or I'm pushing
college but definitely weird for me when
I was younger I mean I played you know I
was 20 playing 15 you know so now I can
still play thirties but it definitely
lends me to do more interesting roles I
think now because I have grown into
myself I Know Who I am I'm much more
confident in Who I am you know when
you're in that twenty late 20s 30s I
kind of squandered a bit because I'm
like why don't really fit here and I
don't really fit here so now that I've
come into my 40s I feel very confident
about where I'm going so what did you
think you didn't fit in because I don't
see you that way but I'm just curious
where as I could see fitting into so
many roles but um well I wasn't quite a
man as funny as that sounds you know I'm
in my 30s and my early 30s were a really
tough time in this business because I I
started out by getting big roles right
away I mean I started working my first
audition I books and you know my career
started kind of like here and then as I
was 30 I kind of had to backtrack a
little bit and sort of sort out what a
lot of actors go through in the
beginning of their careers trying to get
to hustle and so I kind of had to like
step back a little bit and reassess
everything so I wasn't quite an older
guy
you know to play this role and I wasn't
quite younger mouth fell it's just kind
of interesting enough my early 30s it
was an awkward stage for me as weird as
that is